okay so I absolutely love Ultimates like
it's it's I think really one of the
standout titles and all-new
all-different marvel and Marvel now 2.0
the sad thing is that like not a lot of
people know about it or they don't know
what's going on in it and so because
that they're just like missing out on
this amazing stuff so I'm really hoping
this video will serve the purpose of
letting you guys know what's going on
and you guys will go out and buy it
because it is an awesome title so for
those of you guys who were curious about
like cosmic Marvel about like Eternity
and Galactus and all that kind of stuff
this takes care of all that Ultimates
covers all that we've covered all the
ultimate stuff up to this point but it
covers all that but the big question
that people have had is who chained
eternity that was the big question we
saw in all-new all-different Ultimates
that somebody had basically put eternity
the living embodiment of the multiverse
in Chains now what Al Ewing is doing
here is actually offered a little bit of
a change with regards to the Eternity
concept and we'll get to that once we
get further into this video because what
we're basically going to get is the
origin of everything that's ever existed
in Marvel Comics from the time the very
first universe took form up until the
collapse of the multiverse now and what
not really what happened but in terms of
some of the history of the various
different multiverses that have existed
in between so it'll all make sense by
the time we get to it I won't be
confusing in any way but the idea here
is that we initially pick up with Adam
Brashear with blue Marvel initially it
is kind of like you know staring into
and trying to figure out what's going on
with everything because remember the
Ultimates basically disbanded during the
events of Civil War two when Carol
Danvers was using the Ultimates as a way
to basically carry out her goal of
keeping crime from happening before it
happened of course Ulysses and all that
kind of good stuff but because of the
fact that a lot of people hated Civil
War - but what a Ewing ended up doing
was basically bringing the Ultimates
back together to answer the question of
who chained eternity and it was only
when the Ultimates had learned this had
happened but they began to ask the
question of what was going on now from
this point we transition over to over to
Monica Rambeau
and the funny thing about Monica Rambeau
is spectrum is that historically she's
played a lot of different roles I mean
she's been captain universe I believe I
want to say she was Captain Marvel
at one point um but the whole idea here
I think she was captain universe I think
she was just Captain Marvel um I think
it was I'm confusing her with a girl
from Hickman's Avengers of New Avengers
the random chick who is in a car wreck
and and suddenly saved by the Cynthia's
of the universe
came captain universe we'll cover that
next year but Monica Rambeau is played
Captain Marvel for a time and and the
whole idea is that she was always kind
of considered to be a throwaway
character by a lot of readers in the
sense that she never really received her
time in the Sun and the cool thing about
this is that she actually gets it
because what al viewing has really been
harping on with her character is how
powerful she is that she is in effect
pure energy that the physical body that
we see is not her true form that Adam
Brashear looks at her and sees her for
what she really is which is basically
just pure energy in the form of a human
meaning she can basically do anything
now we kind of knew that with her
character to a degree in a sense because
she was able to manipulate all facets of
the energy spectrum she could turn into
anything any form of energy she could
use any form of energy that kind of
thing but I mean she can't like warp
reality on a universal scale like she
can't manipulate molecules or anything
like that she's effectively just a giant
battery and so it's really really cool
to see what kind of limits her powers
can be pushed to but again in the midst
of all this what is it up happening is
Monica's basically just kind of whisked
away and all of it seems to have been
done by Connor Sims now again Connor
Sims as we know him is basically an T
man of course we covered him during the
the origin story of blue Marvel but he
had since been turned into a Herald of
Galactus and the reason why was because
of Galactus realized that eternity had
been changed but not knowing who it was
that did it basically said if there is a
being out there that can chain eternity
then I need a new Herald and that Herald
is going to go to the ultimate bring the
Ultimates to me and make them my heralds
and so the idea of Galactus was to use
the ultimate asses heralds essentially
functioning as protectors of the
universe the way it existed now and
that's exactly what happens the various
Ultimates are basically whisked away by
Connor Sims to a Galactus ship tattoo
and they're met with America Chavez who
basically says look there is a mass of a
massive threat coming and we have to
find a way to deal with this now America
Chavez is one of these characters who's
only ever really as interesting as a
story that she's in she's not inherently
interesting by herself we know this
because ultimate like America number one
came out sold really well and then
America number two tanked so she's just
not really an interesting character but
for what she does here in the ultimate
this makes her interesting and that's
why I say and Marvel Comics a lot of the
characters are not inherently intriguing
it's the events surrounding them that
make them intriguing for example Captain
is not an intriguing character but it's
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers that
make make Captain Universe intriguing
the same thing with star brand a night
mask and a lot of those characters
it's the events going on around them
that make them interesting as opposed to
just the characters themselves now of
course America Chavez being here is
basically saying there's something wrong
with the multiverse there's some threat
out there in the multiverse that's
screwing everything up and we are going
to have to try to find a way to
essentially fix it now of course the
other half of this is that Galactus and
Connor Sims basically take off and they
actually end up meeting directly with
the Linea tribunal and master order in
Lord Chaos now the reason why this
happens is because of the fact that
we've seen this before in the previous
discussion of that the previous videos
that we've done that the first problem
the ultimate solved is basically solving
all the problems in the universe the
first proud a major problem they solved
was Galactus they looked at Galactus and
they said him being the devourer of
worlds is a threat to all life in
existence what we're going to do is
we're basically going to evolve him into
his perfect form and make him the life
bringer now the reason why Galactus
being made the life bringer was such a
huge deal in terms of the contents of
this story is that from the perspective
of master order and Lord chaos they
represent opposing size right I mean
we've had this discussion countless
times and we'll have this discussion
again when we basically remaster
Infinity Gauntlet and when we do
infinity war and all that cosmic stuff
next year the whole idea is that the
universe is basically in balance there
is order and there's chaos and you can't
have one without the other a perfectly
ordered universe would look crazy
a perfectly chaotic universe would look
just as crazy jim Starlin showed us
those two things when we basically went
inside the minds of Thanos and Adam
warlock to see a perfect universe in
Adam warlocks mind and a chaotic
universe and Thanos is mine so because
of this they basically work in unison
the issue here is that in the mind in
the perspective of master order and Lord
chaos Galactus is supposed to be the
devourer of worlds that's his role in
the universe that's the role that he
plays in the same way that master order
our order and Lord chaos play the role
of two opposites with the in-betweener
being the reconciliation between order
and chaos in the same way that eternity
plays the role of being the living
embodiment of the universe and so on
Galactus is supposed to play the role of
the world of our now because of the fact
that he's not doing this they end up
invoking the Living Tribunal because
remember the Living Tribunal is
basically the judge whenever there's a
disagreement the Living Tribunal is
invoked and the tribunal will determine
whether or not the actions of a being is
are basically in violation of cosmic
order which is to say if there were a
being that were nigh uncatchable unit
would say this person is not part of the
cosmic order they're an aberration
they're a screw up that was the whole
thing with a character of protégé who
basically copied the powers of everybody
that he saw and it made him Bert
virtually godlike to the point that even
protege was able to go again go
toe-to-toe with the Living Tribunal and
so the idea here is to basically have
Galactus on trial and say Galactus is
supposed to be the devourer of worlds if
he's not doing this he's not part of the
cosmic order he's not maintaining his
rule he's going against cosmic law
ultimately the Living Tribunal says no
if this is going to be the case with
Galactus then this is basically his
perfect iteration this is his perfect
form he has moved in the direction moved
into his next stage of evolution he's
not violating any laws now the issue
that's made with this is that the Living
Tribunal also establishes that because
of the fact that the all-new
all-different marvel universe and even
multiverse is still new that the cosmic
law is still being made the hierarchy is
still being constructed so for those of
you guys who were asking for a new
hierarchy for only while different
Marvel a new cosmic and power hierarchy
we can't do that yet because we don't
know what the hierarchy is and this
plays out when master order and Lord
chaos kill the living tribunal now again
because of the fact that they kill the
tribunal and essentially take his place
what they do in turn is they move on and
say we are going to impose our will
we're going to impose our order on to
everything we're going to make the
universe bend to our will it's going to
be how we believe it should be it's
going to function the way that we think
it should now in the midst of all this
we end up coming across some sort of
crazy enigmatic kind of energy that
makes its presence known to the
ultimates now of course as this energy
is fought by The Ultimates as as energy
begins to coalesce we end up finding out
that this energy is the shaper of worlds
now this is really kind of cool because
the shaper of worlds is basically a
cosmic cube that went crazy now the
funny thing about this is that the
shaper of worlds cannot really do
anything on its own because it's a
cosmic cube a cosmic cube is basically
bound to the intention of the person who
wields it and so it would be like if I
gave you a pencil all right the pencil
can only do what you do with it the
pencil can't draw by itself the pencil
needs you to pick it up and draw
something on a piece of paper and that's
how a
Cosmic Cube works the cosmic you can't
do anything on its own this shaper of
worlds is the exact same way now what
the shaper basically tells us is that
when it came into existence in the
Marvel Universe before Secret Wars that
it basically functioned in all the ways
that we saw it do its whole thing that
would be a villain it would show up it
would do some crazy things here and
there but when the collapse of the
multiverse took place the shaper of
worlds was effectively assured outside
all space and time and when it did it
saw something out there it's off force
out there that nobody knew about and so
because of that it basically confined
this confined him down to it to a
singular point where a more or less
drove him insane but it also made his
energy signature you know incorporeal
and so what it's been doing is basically
reconstituting itself down to a
recognizable form which isn't you know
that in turn harnessed by Adam Brashear
and The Ultimates more or less for
safekeeping and so because of the fact
that the Living Tribunal has essentially
been killed the first step of Master
Order and Lord chaos is bonding
themselves into the being logos and then
to also try to basically force Galactus
back into being the devourer of worlds
in terms of them individually they're
not able to force Galactus back into the
position of being the devourer of worlds
and so for the most part they launch an
attack but nothing really happens
Galactus just fixes himself and then he
calls it a day but what al viewing also
does here is he invokes a guy by the
name of Jim Henson now Jim Henson is a
new creation he's something newly
introduced by Al Ewing and so was a lot
of the stuff that we're going to see
with a group called the Troubleshooters
and these are basically kind of recruits
that have been organized under Jim
Henson for the purpose of operating as
like a black ops team or like a recon
team and intelligence team now initially
Jim Henson is contacted by Phil Vaughn
of course we know him as the
governmentally the liaison who's been
tasked with monitoring the Ultimates of
course the reason why the government did
that is because of the amount of power
the Ultimates possess and the idea that
they were basically running around in
space without anybody keeping an eye on
them and so what this does is this
basically reveals to us that both Phil
vaad and Jim Henson were part of a group
called the first Eternity battalion now
we're not gonna learn a whole lot about
them but we're gonna learn a little bit
more here in a little here in a little
while just enough to kind of give us
some context and that's really about it
and it makes sense just because these
are characters that are being introduced
it would really be way too much
information if we got origin stories for
all these guys over the course of a
six-issue story which is it'd be way too
long the way too convoluted
to confusing anyone throw everybody off
and so we're basically just kind of
given this a little bit of information
about Jim Henson but the idea here is
that from Phil Watts perspective Jim
Henson as well as this guy Simon Razvi
which we'll learn about him here in a
minute
um the idea is that because the
Ultimates are more or less running
around with any without anybody keeping
an eye on them and because of the fact
that they basically disbanded and then
reformed against the wishes of the
federal government the Troubleshooters
are being sent in to monitor the
ultimate secretly to investigate their
base of operations to make sure they're
not up to anything nefarious and to also
essentially bring them in and say you
guys are not supposed to be banded
together you guys have to answer to the
government in terms of why you're doing
this now jumping back to master order
and lord chaos again because of the fact
that they failed in their attempts to to
force Galactus back into his normal
state we end up having Connor Sims
whisked away by Galactus as soon as the
Living Tribunal died basically Galactus
said okay these are popping off things
are going crazy get out of here go get
the ultimate to tell them what's going
on that was one of the coolest moments
was really basically just kind of
whisked him away because that's when you
know that things were getting incredibly
serious and that's the coolest thing is
because Galactus is such an imposing
character in Marvel Comics such a
powerful character in Marvel Comics that
when he's with his Herald and things
begin to sort of panic you can almost
kind of see him looking at the situation
a little fearful and just kind of
whispering - Connor Sims look man go
tell the Ultimates what's going on
before things are too late and like
whisking the ultimate you know whisking
him away to go find the ultimate so it's
really cool because it's a great way to
show us the gravity of the situation now
because master order and Lord chaos were
unable to force their their power onto
onto Galactus they travel to the
in-between and remember the in-betweener
was created by master order and Lord
chaos for the purpose of basically
having a balance of physical
representation of the balance between
order and chaos but by absorbing the
in-betweener into them and then with
with master order absorbing you know
Lord chaos into himself what basically
ends up happening here is we end up
having a new leaf or a newly created
being formed called
logos and this is really kind of a cool
idea because now what it gives us is a
new cosmic entity and it's actually
pretty interesting because the first
thing this cosmic entity does is it
looks around and it says all these
Celestials and so on and so forth
they're all aberrations they're all
things that do not need to exist they're
held there holdovers from the way things
used to be
a new order must be maintained a new
universe has been created and the cosmic
landscape must reflect this new universe
and so what happens is logos obliterates
every last one of the Celestials save
for one and the one celestial that is
saved is essentially the one above all
of the of the Celestials now this brings
into sharp relief the question of the
one overall how does a function this is
a super simple answer there's two
versions of the one above all there is
the god of the Marvel multiverse the one
that we tried to kill and failed and
then there's the one above all celestial
they're two distinctly different beings
don't worry people get them confused all
the time so it's cool don't don't sweat
it if you're kind of a little thrown off
by it you're not the only one a lot of
folks kind of get thrown off by that but
we'll just call him the top celestial
just for the sake of keeping things easy
even then this is really the only time
we see him but top celestial is
basically saved by the never Queen now
the never Queen was actually a Dan Slott
creation as far as I'm aware and she
originally appeared in Silver Surfer but
the never Queen was really more of like
a plot device that Dan Slott made but
because she was established to be a
cosmic entity she's basically been ruled
over and all the other stories that
involved cosmic entities but the never
Queen basically exists outside of all
things that currently exists and she
represents things that could possibly
exist so again we're really getting into
the realm of hypotheticals so on and so
forth but because of the fact that
everything happening in the universe is
taking place in the present she's always
one step ahead she's always in the
future she always represents the
possibility of what could be so the
never Queen is composed of the
possibility of you going left instead of
going right the never Queen is composed
of the possibility of you waking up
instead of dying
she's just composed of all the
possibilities that could exist that's
what makes up who she is so again it's
kind of crazy but it but she fits
perfectly into the realm of abstract
characters now the problem with this is
that in the midst of the Troubleshooters
residing inside the base of operations
for the Ultimates their presence
culminates in the Ultimates arriving to
see them there and so what is it
happening is the Ultimates face off
against the Troubleshooters and it's
kind of a cool conflict to see it's not
wildly significant but it's cool to see
their various counter balances but what
is up happening here is Jim Henson keeps
tapping it as something called the Sai
force now we don't know a whole lot
about what the Sai force is we simply
just know that it's there but the big
guy who's really important to focus on
here is Razvi this
I initially goes against blue Marvel
Adam Brashear and then easily overpowers
him and the biggest question asked here
is that if Adam Brashear is one of the
most powerful beings in existence in
Marvel Comics then how much more
powerful could Rosco really be if he's
going to overpower Adam Brashear in his
entirety so again what seems to be the
indication is that this Rosco guy is a
guy who's not supposed to be here ed
he's someone who's a bit of an
aberration he's a guy that's not what he
appears to be and so again in the middle
of this battle between The Ultimates and
the trouble shooters logo's returns to
Galactus and forces him back into being
the devourer of worlds and when I first
read this I was just like wow like it
blew my mind because logos is basically
like you're going to go back to being
who you were whether you want to be or
not and so it's kind of this impurity
that spilled all over Galactus and one
of the final words he says is I hunger
now the depiction of Galactus as he
appears here in terms of how he's drawn
is designed to be that way he looks
screwed up he looks wrong he looks
corrupted that's exactly how it's
supposed to be that's how he's supposed
to appear simply because of the fact
that this is not his normal state he's
being forced back into an artificial
state because remember he basically
evolved into his next stage which was
the life bringer basically the ability
to create life as opposed to destroying
it but what also ends up happening here
is that Rosco emerges in the midst of
this fight with the ultimate and
basically becomes this sheer wrecking
force absolutely decimating every single
member of The Ultimates now of course
Galactus basically teleports back to
where everybody's located at what almost
immediately Falls and so what we end up
finding out is that with regards to
Rosco being here with regards to you
know all these different things that are
going on with logos with master order
lord chaos all of this has basically
been implemented itself by something
called the first firmament and this is
when we start to get into the timeline
of things making sense now it kind of
boggled me a little bit because up until
this point in the story things seem very
disjointed all over the place and it was
a good read but I would rather have this
timeline you know at the beginning of
the story
that being said having it at the end
actually makes it a little more
impactful just because of the fact that
it gives us all the answers that we've
been looking for all this time and so
what happens as Al Ewing goes all the
way back to the very beginning of all
things now in Marvel Comics we knew this
was the case right like you know before
Secret Wars you had Marvel the
multiverse all that kind of
the universe that you think of when you
think of Marvel's so when spider-man
first appeared when the Incredible Hulk
first appeared Iron Man all that kind of
good stuff of course we had the universe
that Galactus healed from the multiverse
that I guess really the universe before
the current version of the multiverse
and then we had you know all these
different universes and so on and so
forth dating back to the point when the
very first universe came into existence
somewhere along the line in Marvel
Comics what we end up finding out here
is that this being the first firmament
basically created life as the singular
representation of the very very first
universe the firmament made a group
called the aspirants what Al Ewing is
drawing on here is he's actually drawing
on Karen Gillan I think it is his run of
iron man which was absolutely amazing
but one of the things that cure and
Gillan established was that at some
point in the history of the universe
that there were a massive number of
Celestials but there was a war that had
broken out between the Celestials and
the aspirants now we didn't know what
the aspirants look like we didn't know
their history all we knew is that they
were just some group with power equal to
that of the Celestials and it resulted
in the aspirants basically overtaking
the Celestials pushing them to the brink
of almost complete and total extinction
in an act of desperation the Celestials
created something called the God killer
armor and the god killer armor basically
obliterated the aspirants and pushed
them to the brink of all destruction now
that is the most recent version of the
Marvel Universe so we'll call that the
seventh Marvel multiverse
in this first Marvel multiverse what
we're seeing here right now this is
basically just a war that broke out
between the asteroids and the Celestials
which is always destined to do but in
this war that initially broke out it led
to the destruction of that universe and
when the universe was reborn as the
second universe the the first firmament
basically spread out and so what we
basically get up to this point is that
there was a singular universe with the
destruction of the of the first universe
it exploded into a multiverse and so
with the creation of this multiverse
came the cosmic entities that we know
that eternity and so on and so forth and
so because of that in this basically the
second multiverse things progressed the
wars repeated yet again the war between
the aspirins the war between the
Celestials it kept happening over and
over and over again throughout every
single multiverse that was created up to
the seventh multiverse which went into
secret Wars which went into the eighth
multiverse as we have it right now but
despite all these different conflicts
that had happened the first firmament
was always in the back
this energy force was just always in the
back watching everything unfold and the
first firmament was plotting its revenge
was plotting its way to basically
eliminate all things in existence we
take the universe back unto itself and
then be the sole universe in existence
basically consolidating everything back
down and so because of this the first
firmament began to launch a series of
campaigns aimed at basically
destabilizing all things in existence
and trying to create aberrations that
would make eternity extremely weak due
to the fact that following the new
formation of the universe or the
multiverse eternity was already in a
weakened state so it would allow the
allow the first storm into basically
overpower eternity put it in Chains and
then begin the process of destroying
everything now the reason why I say that
a Ewing is basically going through and
offering changes is because historically
speaking in Marvel Comics eternity was
the physical representation of a
universe and so there were an infinite
number of eternity zhh one for each
universe the idea had been toyed with
that there was a singular eternity that
made up the multiverse but there was
nothing to indicate that it was actually
true what Al viewing is doing here is
making it true al viewing is saying now
there's a multiversal eternity there's
one eternity that represents or is the
physical embodiment of the multiverse
inside that multiversal eternity are all
the infinite number of universes and one
eternity for each of those universes so
again it's a little interesting you know
at the very least but again it basically
expands the Marvel cosmology now of
course switching back to the conflict as
it exists right now of course what we
end up doing is we end up having Connor
Sims basically resurrected by the
combined efforts of Monica Rambeau and
Adam Brashear and so because of the fact
that Connor Sims is brought back a
Connor sim is basically containing
what's left of the life bringer energy
essentially takes himself directly to
Galactus and merges himself with
Galactus to a degree in the sense that
he disperses himself into Galactus as a
result Galactus is reborn as the life
bringer and then destroys rots Voe and
in doing so learns everything that Ross
foe knows which is basically the first
firmament the idea that this first
firmament has struck first that this
entire event
everything we've seen up to this point
is the first battle it's the opening
salvo it's the first skirmish and the
first firmament intends to launch a
massive campaign against the entire
multiverse destroying essentially
everything and bringing all things into
existence back into itself and then
being a singular universe unto itself
going forward but anyway if you guys are
new here two comments explain makes you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like I love
Ultimates it's definitely one of my
favorite one of my favorite stories up
to this point it's pretty stellar like I
love the cosmic stuff though so anyway
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end now catch you guys later
peace
[Music]